[Music]
in childhood ruined news Oh gonna buy
the week D week die with thee I don't
know you have a week D week dy dy ah we
could die
YouTube says it will crack down on
bizarre videos targeting children it
will crack down on bizarre video stories
how does that mean like prank videos on
children laughing but what kind of
videos targeting children bizarre
bizarre baby there's videos targeting
children there art what market business
oh is it like the one where they show
you like the little toys that they're
talking about but then there's like some
[ __ ] hidden [ __ ] in there um like
it's either animations of characters
their childhood character like
spider-man Elsa people like that or they
actually dress up as them and everything
on what the guys are twerking and and
they're like doing weird [ __ ] right so I
didn't like murdering each other - yeah
and everything this is a good screen I'm
not sure whose channel this is but this
is like some of the videos that are
being targeted like so it looks
kid-friendly and you click it looks like
a kid and it's like dudes like bending
over super sexually so it's weird this
is like this is I go under the clip baby
no you're not allowed to have clickbait
anymore right no that's what it is
though you click that and it is guys
started dressing like spider-man and
[ __ ] yeah because like the one of the
titles I read I was like learning colors
exactly whether you click on it and all
of a sudden like some dudes do a sexual
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] content I'm gonna
show you guys a video clip of h3h3 Ethan
here explaining or talking about some of
these [ __ ] up channel I hope these
kids are hitting the dislike button
Ethan's cool he is cool if it's not a
[ __ ] old creepy guy putting a syringe
of the babies Ethan Bradberry [ __ ]
face down ass up and a spider-man
costume and the strangest thing about
this whole thing is that the weirder the
videos the more successful they are
almost it's like the ones where
spider-man's eyes
being torn out and you know squash and
it Hulk eats the [ __ ] fetus like
these are the ones killing it as you can
see in this video entitled spider-man
and Elsa kiss
spider-man lunges from taking a [ __ ] -
immediately raping frozen Elsa on the
floor of a bathroom this is one of the
hottest kids videos of the year oh [ __ ]
I I don't know if that's reason to rape
fetish at an early age which is a
wonderful boon to society get her Spidey
yeah yeah she saw his full video I don't
know if it was that one but he did do
another thing about [ __ ] Ethan
Bradberry like those guys used to be
these East Coast pranksters and then
they got caught for doing fake pranks
and all that yeah and then they started
doing these weird [ __ ] kid costume
videos so they would go around and it
was so weird and then I realized that
they were parroting this existing kids
show that these adults made so like
these adults dress up and like Elsa and
like spider-man and then like they have
music like they did it and then they're
just playing it's not creepy so that
that one the adults that are in the
costume it's cute it's like a kid it's
like a kids show but with the doats
right but what they did is they parodied
that but made it really [ __ ] weird
and it and now all these weird [ __ ]
things started happening like I don't
know if they started it all but then
like there's just a bunch of weird kid
show [ __ ] where are these views coming
from one of these kids like 8 million
kid views or is it 8 million I think it
probably probably stars that way like
where kids are watching it but then
because of that view count it starts
getting suggestive more and more and
then it becomes like teenagers or adults
who are weird it's more it's like more
shock value content like have you seen
this this just [ __ ] weird and people
watch it jump start is the kids you just
want your kid to [ __ ] watch some
spider-man cartoon while you do the
dishes and [ __ ] and you click that video
thinking it's okay and then it's
spider-man [ __ ] twerking and throwing
his nuts in front of else's face and
[ __ ]
that's really odd man and you look back
you're like [ __ ] washing the dishes
and you look back and it's like wow [ __ ]
dishes breaking [ __ ] you grab that a kid
like goddamn it what the hell man yeah
so now uh YouTube is announced that it
will no longer allow creators to
monetize on videos which are made
inappropriate by using family-friendly
characters and so there's just saying
like they're gonna be putting a stop to
that that they are in the process of
implementing a new policy that age
restricts that kind of content on the
YouTube main app when it's flagged and
so that way it will not be because any
age restricted content is not allowed at
all on the YouTube kid that and so
that's cool that's awesome
- it's weird yeah but then apparently
some of these crazy-ass videos are
getting through it's crazy that they're
going viral - that's the crazy part
it shows who's watching it too because
if moms are catching it then they would
flag it you know and be like a wuss but
if it's just like being passed around
just oh yeah that's like the new policy
they're trying to put in here so if
they're now with this new one is if it's
on the YouTube main app and it gets
someone's able to be like wait this
isn't right like buy it for age
restriction then that's when it'll stop
it from going into YouTube kids because
then apparently there's like this kind
of buffer time when a video is uploaded
on the main app for it to go on the kids
app so in that that middle time is when
they're hoping that they will be able to
flag the appropriate video
what does it say about us so if these
videos are hitting like 8 million views
maybe there is a demand out demand for
videos like this is shock valid but did
you see the stupid [ __ ] did you see this
baby but there's multiple ones you're
not getting sick of it right so cuz if I
would I would say like if there was like
three or something and that's
circulating I think what I'm saying is
this isn't new though this is like
late-night Cartoon Network [ __ ] this you
know it's Rinna's Tempe yeah it's
running snippy essentially that's
exactly what this it's worse than
reading stuff you do if you watch it
you'll feel like creeped out like it's
worse than solid bar but it's just like
cuz meanness to me was just like
eyeballs or whatever but this is
actually walking we have babies but I
got this what I'm saying is like if
there is a market and demand for this
that maybe YouTube shouldn't stop it no
yeah so then that's what YouTube is
saying like if there you know people can
like their work [ __ ] that's good for you
but we're just trying to stop it from
getting kids gotcha is that gonna affect
someone who markets the kids like do
they do their upload now go directly to
the kids anymore already I think it's
already a buffer I think I'm I'm not
clear exactly if that's already
something that's been implemented but
that's just something that's mentioned
here that that's what will be happening
it's weird people jacking off to it
probably all the way you drive up to
anything but eight I mean clearly that's
your point right there look at the
animations and everything like this upon
you see which is weird so yeah but that
stuff looks like normal this stuff is
like I've seen some of those videos dude
it's like what Dolph [ __ ] is going on
like I'm a weird [ __ ] and I
think that should that should has walls
sure creepy animations expensive too so
people are investing time I haven't seen
any of the animation stuff but I've seen
all the the fake spider-man the guys in
costumes need a full-on stories and
skits Wow it's just [ __ ] weird I
thought that's one video that I had it
had millions of views and it was like
Elsa spider-man some other characters
like in live-action not animation
they're all just like them and the
entire video was unedited and you could
see the people saying like cut good go
that way and then it was just like so
poorly produced and I had millions of
views
what were they doing was that it just
been standing there was it oh it was
like it was just stupid things like
they'll go with like a really so strange
what I remembered was the fact that they
just left it and they just didn't give a
[ __ ] and 1/2 million if Dasha gets
millions of views there's another video
I saw winners like this naked asian guy
during karate today watch that video
better
[Laughter]
on the beach yeah Ellen's way better
than our married mothers
maybe that's what people don't want they
don't want things that are done right
everything is so like so view based like
I just missed the days what we just
create just a create right whether I
just got views or it doesn't [ __ ]
matter man you crate from here and if
you like it that's all that [ __ ]
matters you know and if you're popular
of it you're popular folk cares you know
it turned into like faking things like
the fame crane and it's so interesting
because even when I came back to YouTube
you know my thing was like I told people
from the get-go I just made whatever the
[ __ ] I want to make like nothing to do
it you know and they're like true Craner
yeah they're like I've we mr. Olsen I'll
give a [ __ ]
bit like I like my stuff you know and
that's the only way I could continue to
do this is if I enjoy what I'm doing and
if that's not the case you're just gonna
get garbage dude you're preaching to the
choir right now that's exactly what my
channel is like people don't even know
what my original channel was just when
it got popular like cuz I just happen to
do like a vs. series for like star wars
right and you were like I wish you were
back to your old days because I do
everything can they kept they call me
during that that way that way like look
at my first video it was a [ __ ] video of
me my friends at a grocery store and
short films like that and like it wasn't
always like this reviews aren't
appreciated but at the same time when
you started creating for yourself you
can always create for yourself rain and
it's fun that way it keeps me going you
know what I mean so yeah sometimes you
get a weird [ __ ] video sometimes you
get a sketch sometimes whatever like
just don't expect certain content just
know that I'm gonna create and I'll
always be there that's why I love our
fans it's like we have some of the most
loyal
it's like some some veterans are like 8
year veterans were there with us through
Josh's blue balls yeah I mean like dude
even if that video got views like come
on man like we got some hardcore awesome
fans and like I would much rather have a
solid 100,000 views of people that are
like down then millions of views that
just click because they think I'm
bizarre yeah
it doesn't make no sense cuz it's not
it's not true to yourself and it's just
like it's a one-off thing you're not
gonna be you know sitting there just
doing
it's crazy [ __ ] for the [ __ ] of it yeah
you know didn't I do all right
that's actually a real business model to
is to find 1,000 true fans it doesn't
work so much for you to because it is
view base but if you're like selling a
product like for instance I'm writing a
book and everything so all I need to do
is find a thousand true fans and then
every time something's released and
they'll pay for that a thousand true
fans for YouTube too though because like
aside from just like we talked about it
and like on jump cut to like it's aside
from just like catering to everybody if
you have a thousand people that love you
they'll also invest into your other
opportunities as well even with your
book Li you've got those thousand true
fans that's a thousand people that are
my book exactly so it works the same
thing with YouTube too
it's a little bit it's a little bit
different though you know yeah I don't
want to be like too popular cuz then
that's when like it gets difficult to be
yourself because there's too many
different people that are like you
shouldn't be saying this or usually I
love our couple hundred thousand people
that are just down with us you know and
more the merrier if not it's
understandable
[Music]
[Music]